ça sent l'été a été le cas qu'est-ce
qu'on fait l'été ont triplé dans les
danses de l'été donc on va tous faire
une danse de l'été et on va désigner le
meilleur danseur de l'été c'est
maintenant qu'on va le décider parce
qu'après partir en grande terre va
danser bim je suis là attention va
démarrer avec géraldine maillet très
fort on va démarrer très fort il m'a dit
tu peux tu peux me dire c'est toujours
habillé ou gitane donc mais non elle a
bien un peu difficile bien elle est
magnifique il est ouvert à des mal et je
bête pas c'est qu'on s'est battu
non non rien
ça
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est vrai tu t'entends la cpu
mais de loin le cas des voeux qui fait
tout seul à l'avoir offert mais c'est
très content de me coller à vous les
mecs il ya un délire la crise comme
c'est l'habitude d'effacer les plus
chaudes et rock qu'est ce qu'il a lu
fier des bourgeois c'est les plus
chaudes
alors si dans les bourgeois mais ça
marche encore en tout cas vous êtes
magnifique qui rate vous aussi vous êtes
très beau
[Musique]
franchement ça me touche énormément de
notre vote pas parce que oui il savait
ce qui est beau ou une femme de gauche
et alors je vais vous donner des
lunettes parce qu'apparemment il ya un
problème en ce moment ça vous échappe
votre beauté vous échappe c'est sa
cuisse échappe à beaucoup de monde
c'est pour ça qu'il est beau sinon son
adversaire tonéo bagnato temps est
magnifique je regrette parce que
j'écarte de le dire après c'est fini
mais je prends beaucoup de cas les
calmants qui m'ont filé cette fois rien
ne se passe plus rien non ce soir et ça
ça va revenir c'est toi ah bah quoi le
tire-fesses non plus de les rassurer
voilà on continue
si tu fais là dans ce que j'ai envie de
te gifle et non sur la vie de ma mère tu
fais la norges comme ça avec tâtonner sa
danse à lui manquer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
coiffée répondait zapata dans sa masse
et là je suivais l'acheter à distribuer
dans une digue du mois tu dois être très
en vu rouge pour voter pour le meilleur
danseur bt pour avoir dit ouah c'est
géraldine mallet des meilleurs j'ai une
baisse
on a démarré très fort c'est au tour
maintenant stopper ou isaac washington
tu vas nous faire
jean michel maire alors arrête si tu
fais ta bouche avant ses collègues
continent
oui mais je n'ai qu'une juge eut mon
cher nous supporter de ne se porte plus
d'attention c'est parti c'est là qu'a
livré le faire dans deux ans
hélas pas mais là bas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est moi
allez merci quatre jeunes chauriennes st
jean mi il a tout donné un bal à genoux
vont pas tout pour l'instant c'est à
aller en or le même niveau avec quelqu
un qu a souvent gagné le concours de
danse dans tpm p aa
à votre avis de qui cette fois non c'est
pas kelly non c'est pas l'heure du lever
gambettes l'attaquant des normes et vous
n'avez pas vue l'autre thème touche
quand il ne sait pas ce que vous avez
d'alema flammes et vous êtes un final
j'adore ce pantalon blanc ah ouais non
mais c'est vrai qu'il vous fait au coeur
ça vous fait un joli fessier non à
négocier nous on n'a pas vu et mélodies
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît lm bonne note je suis
questions à poser ballon statut il fait
le csa et moi un petit gars devant moi
aussi bah ouais huit jours que j'ai rien
fait c'est vrai c'est dès 2001 l hôtel
c'est comme il est premier de grue
cenovus jean-pierre valero on va
enchaîner tout cas avec isabelle c'est
parti mon coeur
[Musique]
voilà
impossible
le sol et l'eau permet aux nano
m
[Musique]
[Rires]
vous continuez à voter
on a le maître par le meilleur danseur
de ces 25 dernières années les mecs si
c'est pas maxime atomique
les gens qui m'a lancé jean-luc sur
corner je suis fan de ce gars c'est toi
plaisir
la première fois que tu me lancer un
troisième partie est choqué les familles
sont lancés
[Musique]
tha
j'aimerais
voilà mon pote jean luc dans ccb et
l'autre elle est à fond sur la tête de
ma mère
on dirait qu'elle est en toi un concours
de danse où elle va gagner attention on
va enchaîner avec celui qui est pour moi
actuellement
celui qui a le plus de potentiel à venir
quand même les premiers niveaux dans sa
part mathieu de mathieu hynix et les
voitures dans ce rapport a
malheureusement hamas avait battu rumba
les sens il est là vraiment on
observateurs merci pour l'instant le
meilleur danseur pour vous dire mais
déjà la soca dance elle était
moyennement fait vous étiez un petit peu
loin la soca dance et tu rentres la
culture entre le genou les nous mais je
peux vraiment à peine mais tu montes
juste le départ un accord bilatéral
fermer le départ c'est curieux je rentre
chez nous
ce jour là c'est la technique
prosociales plus compliqué que je suis
fait duc tu es d'accord
non non c'est gens que je suis navré de
gens qui n'a jamais ménagé général à
l'art qui troque là et je fais toi c'est
pas mal voilà on est sur les studios
mondiaux jeunesse s'est senti coincé
dans les bijoux d'aller voir un gars qui
agace non mais c'est pour ça que je
t'aime allé lècher revanche et avec
maxime gay ni de quelle façon on va
enchaîner avec fruits de la passion
franck manchon c'est l'anniversaire de
francky vincent qui va laisser un
message pourquoi il veut ton si c'est
parti
[Musique]
non
pour moi c'est parce que y'a rien vu de
pire
non mais c'est ça le vôtre toutes
mesures potentielles catastrophes
annoncées soient macarena renard et
c'est bon là pas attention fonctionner
avec benjamin castaldi benji et razzano
non c'est un bonheur castaldi et valérie
bénaïm vous continuez à voter sur pour
l'instant c'est isabelle dit la vérité
attention c'est pas la musique
[Musique]
non mais pas toujours
g
[Musique]
en ce sens
et puis
[Musique]
attention la dernière danseuses
s'étaient dit me morice a n'est pas
kelly s'est qualifée novelli hier jean
talon son talon à négocier
[Applaudissements]
m
samphel le qatari
[Musique]
et alors avec annick malheureusement on
me dit que ça n'a pas été diffusée vous
repassez la gorge mais je gère
apparemment le jury n'a pas perdu un
fils je décris toi mais tu es
complètement si elle à l'émission va
être folle même un gars qui ouvre on a
fait ça l'atome mais vraiment merde quoi
magnifique halifax et l'ancien parti
du serveur poule 4
[Musique]